look at this footage from Ecuador it is
a bunch of masked men who invaded a TV
station while it was still live on the
air Ecuador is a place that is
historically been peaceful and beautiful
recently it's been descending into chaos
a few weeks ago this drug lord who was
serving 34 years in prison escaped then
all hell broke loose prisons were taken
over by the inmates guards were held
hostage police officers abducted and
then of course this TV station incident
stuff like this is happening all over
the country and the reason it's
happening now is because the cocaine
trade is changing a lot more drugs are
going to Europe drug cartels are using
this port in Ecuador as a major trade
Hub the number of violent deaths has
doubled since last year a presidential
candidate that was running on
anti-corruption was assassinated as well
as the prosecutor who was investigating
this TV station incident so now like
Mexico and Colombia Ecuador is
descending into a drug war between these
gangs and the government and it is
tearing the country apart I'm going to
keep following this if you want to
better understand global politics follow
along for more